an update now on that breaking news a
man is dead this morning
after a pursuit with metro police ended
with shots fired on the strip which is
why the closure is happening hector
mejia is live on scene there at sahara
in las vegas boulevard with the latest
hi hector
hey there alex and metro police tell us
this is the aftermath of a dangerous
encounter between officers
and a person who had felony warrants and
now this is the investigation unfolding
right behind us the scene is right where
you see those flashing lights
and right now the las vegas strip a
portion of the las vegas strip is shut
down starting at right about sahara
this all started with a traffic stop
just after midnight according to police
as officers with metro police waited for
backup
they say the driver took off they knew
the person behind the wheel had several
felony warrants and considered dangerous
the air unit followed the car then when
the driver turned onto the strip
officers stopped them that's when police
say things took a violent turn
at some point as the officers were
trying to contain the suspect he turned
squared up on the officers and charged
the officers with a knife in his hand
causing the officers to fire rounds at
the suspect
immediately medical personnel were
summoned and declared the subject
deceased on scene
no officers were hurt and we are told
this is the 15th officer involved
shooting of 2020
for metro police and according to
captain sasha larkin
they were worried as soon as the driver
headed for the las vegas strip and they
had to stop the driver before
the driver got anywhere near to any
crowded areas with tourists and now
again las vegas boulevard here still
closed in both directions
that's the latest from the scene we'll
have an update for you ahead in half an
hour reporting live hector mejia
8 news now